hey guys I wanted to talk about side
effects from taking too much apple cider
vinegar or kombucha tea kombucha tea is
a fermented drink very carbonated very
acidic if you haven't had it before so
just because outside of vinegar has a
lot of benefits in kombucha tea also has
great benefits for your digestion
doesn't mean taking excessive amounts is
even better here's some side effects it
can increase your heart rate it can keep
you from sleeping if you have an ulcer
it can aggravate that because these are
acids in which case you wouldn't want to
keep doing this because you want to heal
the ulcer first by correct eating in a
minute fasting chlorophyll maybe the
wheatgrass juice powder would help you
but another symptom would be decreased
oxygen so sometimes your breathing is
going to be off it's like you're going
to be feel like you can't get enough air
so these are some of the symptoms of
acidosis so you push yourself too far to
one side so I remember one time it
happened to me
I drank an entire bottle of kombucha tea
right before bed my pulse rate started
going up couldn't sleep I noticed my
breathing was off so if that happens
just realize that your body's too acidic
so you can take some alkalizing minerals
potassium calcium magnesium or maybe
even a little bit of baking soda to
quickly get rid of those symptoms so you
can sleep but if you're gonna do
kombucha tea especially in the evenings
make sure you only do half of a bottle
not the entire bottle
now with the episode of vinegar you know
if you keep it at 2 teaspoons a day in a
glass of water and not going to be a
problem make sure you use a straw so it
doesn't affect the teeth and if you
drink these and you notice your stomach
is burning chances are you could have an
ulcer or gastritis where the stomach
lining is very raw and sensitive and
inflamed in which case you would not
want to consume these you would want to
take some chlorophyll to start healing
the stomach for a period of months
before you added that back in but just
the fact that you had that burning or
that irritation will give you valuable
information because it could explain why
you've been having certain digestive
issues whether it's gas or indigestion
or bloating and you wouldn't want to
acidify it because the stomach needs
somehow
to heal first cabbage is really good for
that cabbage juice even sauerkraut could
help you heal the stomach all right
thanks for watching hey if you enjoyed
this video press subscribe and I will
definitely keep you updated